hello and welcome to another 3abn today
Bible q a I'm Jason Bradley and one of
the things that I really love about this
program is it shows how many people are
out there in the world searching for
answers to their questions from the word
of God and so we receive so many
questions thought provoking questions
that you submit and maybe you're
watching this program maybe you're
joining us for the first time maybe you
haven't submitted a question I want to
share with you how you may do so you can
text your questions to
618-228-3975 again that's
618-228-3975 or you can email them to
bibleqa at 3abn dot TV again that's
Bible QA at
3abn.tv and if you're on Instagram you
can visit our Instagram page at 3abn
under underscore official and send us a
direct message there again that's at
3abn underscore official and send us
that direct message I want to share with
you something from the word of God it's
taken from Acts chapter 17 verses 10 and
11. then the Brethren immediately sent
Paul and Silas Away by night to Berea
when they arrived they went into the
synagogue of the Jews these were more
fair-minded than those in
thessalonica in that they received the
word with all Readiness and searched the
Scriptures Daily to find out whether
these things were so
we're here to search the scriptures and
we are going to find the answers to your
questions in the word of God and here
with me to discuss this and search the
scriptures together we have Pastor John
lomachang it's great to have you here to
see you Jason call my nephew that's
right Uncle that's right oh we got Uncle
Lumi and next year we have Daniel Perrin
it's great to have you here Daniel yep
good to be here always happy to search
the word with you yes yes and right next
to you is someone I've known for 36
years
um
my precious mom Yvonne Shelton it's
great to have you here thank you it's so
good to be here and you're a first timer
I know I am what do you enjoy about
studying the word of God
there's always something new to learn
you can read a passage several times and
each time you know the Holy Spirit Will
Reveal something else or there'll be
something that is Meaningful or
resonates with you so it's a blessing to
to study the word and to learn each time
like something different amen amen well
before we dive into the word of God
would you have a word of prayer sure
sure
oh Lord we thank you so much for the
privilege of being able to study your
word and we thank you so much for the
Holy Spirit who will be our teacher and
our guide so let every word that's
spoken be reflective of you and honor
you thank you for each participant in
this program and we just pray for that
again that this will be a blessing to
the viewers we pray in Jesus name amen
amen amen thank you Pastor Loma King
we're going to start with you okay what
is the faith of Jesus this comes from C
sturge okay thank you so much C sturge
a unique last name but let me go ahead
and refer to the passage that you may be
thinking about Revelation 14 verse 12.
here is the patience of the Saints here
are those who keep the Commandments of
God and the faith of Jesus notice it
says it doesn't just say they keep the
Commandments of goddesses they keep the
faith of Jesus also it doesn't say they
just have the faith of Jesus or faith in
Jesus but they keep the faith of Jesus
when you look at the Fuller picture
there are two comparisons Revelation
brings out and you find that in
Revelation chapter 14 there are two
connections so since the context of the
faith of Jesus is in the chapter of
Revelation chapter 14 I want to show you
the two contrasts just before I get to
that though the faith of Jesus is a
tried Faith a Victorious Faith a faith
those severely tried did not fail and
the writer of The Book of Luke Luke
chapter 22 verse 31 and 32 the faith of
Jesus is alluded to in verses 31 and 32
when Jesus talks to Peter he said Simon
Simon Satan has asked for you that he
may sift you as wheat but notice what he
says in verse 32 but I have prayed for
you that your faith should not fail so
the faith of Jesus of faith is a faith
that did not fail because Satan Tried
Him but look at the two comparisons
Revelation chapter 14 you find the faith
of Jesus is something that enables us to
do something and in verse 4 of
Revelation 14 it talks about those who
do display or who have the faith of
Jesus it says these are the ones who are
not defiled with women why because they
have the faith of Jesus they are virgins
why because they have the faith of Jesus
that is spiritual versions they are pure
these are the ones who follow the lamb
wherever he goes why because their faith
comes from him these will redeemed from
among men being first fruits to God and
to the lamb why because they represent
him but the two comparisons are
Revelation Chapter 14 verse 11 and
notice the Wicked the Bible says and the
smoke of their torment ascends forever
and ever and they have no rest day or
night why because they don't have the
faith of Jesus that's the biggest reason
why because the contrast is in verse 13.
then I Heard a Voice from Heaven saying
right blessed are the Dead who die in
the Lord from now on yes says the spirit
that they may rest notice the wicked
they have no rest but those who are in
Christ they may rest and it's not just
talking about physical rest but they're
able to rest in the faith of Jesus and
as we know these are the ones who will
see the Three Angels messages Triumph so
what is the faith of Jesus is the faith
that we all need I did a sermon called
the faith of Jesus it's on YouTube you
may want to check that out so the answer
could be more detailed but the faith of
Jesus introduce a tried faith and a
Victorious Faith I like that I like that
the faith of Jesus is the faith that
never failed never fails that's
beautiful that's beautiful Daniel
does the Bible say anything about asking
for donations from a politician now I'm
not quite sure about this question
because it seems like the politician
would be asking for donations from us so
I'll let you take that away all right
and I assume the question refers to
requests for donations that do come from
the politician so in other words should
we give to politicians who are
soliciting donations the Bible does not
describe our system of fundraising for
political parties and candidates and
elections but the biblical principle
here is this you are a steward in other
words everything that you own you don't
opponent God owns it and you simply
manage it for him and we'll give an
account so the question is not should we
invest our money in this candidate or
that one but how would God have us to
invest his money so that it brings about
the greatest possible return for his
kingdom Matthew 6 verse 21 Jesus
speaking in The Sermon on the Mount says
where your treasure is there your heart
will be also and we know this is true
wherever we put our investment of of
ourselves whether it be a hobby or
entertainment or convenience or a
political party that's the thing that is
going to consume not only our time but
our energy our focus and our treasure as
well so where would God have you to
invest your treasure what will last what
will Outlast oh when Jesus was
questioned by pilate right before he was
put to death there in John 18 36 he said
my kingdom is not of this world there is
not a human political Kingdom that is
the one endorsed by heaven and why is
that because this world is passing away
politicians will make speeches and they
will do their best to endorse one
candidate or another and try to convince
you to vote or support for them but God
does not endorse a human political
candidate or party because he's not
campaigning we're human kingdoms because
those things are going to pass away
Philippians 3 verse 20 says that our
citizenship is in heaven from which we
also eagerly await the Savior the Lord
Jesus Christ so what should you do what
should we do with the money uh the
treasure that God has entrusted to us
and the biblical principle of
stewardship begins with returning tithe
always start right there and support
with 10 percent of your income the
gospel sharing Ministry and then as God
lays it upon your heart give an offering
of gratitude to support other Ministries
that God places before you and then ask
God pray about it and say Lord how would
you have me to invest how would you help
me to use these resources so they bring
about
the the advancing of your kingdom and
people can hear about you along with
this question how do we relate to
politics and number one you can support
politicians by praying for them and you
should listen to First Timothy 2 verse
1. therefore I exhort first of all that
supplications prayers intercessions and
give giving of thanks be made for all
men for kings and all who are in
Authority definitely don't withhold your
prayers and then place the matter of
voting your support for political
candidates before God and say God lead
me to decide and to vote if that's what
God leads you to as you would have me to
vote then finally if you find yourself
agreeing with one side or another that
is the opportunity for you to share the
good news about God's kingdom with those
who are like-minded with you hmm great
answer yes pray pray pray pray for our
politicians for sure for sure Mom the
Bible says to eat fruit nuts seeds and
green herbs is it safe to eat mushrooms
since they are a fungus What is the
nutritional purpose of eating them this
comes from John out of Kansas
so Genesis 1 29 sets forth man's
original diet given by God it says and
God said see I've given you every herb
that yields seed which is on the face of
all the Earth and every tree whose fruit
yields seed to you it shall be for food
this sets forth man's original diet
which consisted of fruits nuts seeds and
Grains vegetables came after sin in
Genesis 3 18 God told Adam that he would
eat the herb of the field in other words
vegetables would be added to his diet
interestingly enough there's no mention
of mushrooms anywhere in the Bible so we
have to look at principle here mushrooms
are fungi and they're neither plant nor
animal interest like I always thought
they were plants but they're not plants
or animals they're not plants because
they don't contain chloroplasts and
chloroplasts are the chlorophyll
containing plastids in each plant so
they are not plants but some scientists
even believe that they're closer to the
Animal Kingdom than to plants mushrooms
feed on dead remains of living things
such as other mushrooms of their own
species nutritionally speaking some
mushrooms are immune enhancing there are
some that are good for you and then
there's some that are deadly mushrooms
contain High antioxidant levels with
dozens of nutrients like vitamin D
selenium potassium there are mushrooms
like the maitaki mushroom which improves
the immune system shiitake improves
immune function Ganoderma lucidum which
is the reishi mushroom is known as
lingzer and Chinese medicine and so
it's it's kind of hard because there are
mushrooms that are deadly and we have to
stay away from those they're magic
mushrooms that are psychedelic that
induce all of these other experiences
but
there are 70 to 80 species of poisonous
mushrooms but only a few that are
actually fatal
I think if there's any verse that may
give permission to eat mushrooms it's
found in Genesis 9 3 where God says
every moving thing that lives shall be
food for you I've given you all things
even as the green herbs so if it's if
it's one of these immune enhancing
mushrooms it has like beta glucans and
things that improve immune function it's
okay because they help the body but if
it's one of the deadly mushrooms you
don't want to stay away from it and
don't pick your own mushrooms because a
lot of them the poisonous ones look like
the Edible Ones and you can eat one of
those poison ones and die so be very
careful about how you pick your
mushrooms I guess that kind of applies
to everything be very careful some don't
be deceived
be very careful about how you choose
your mushrooms well mushrooms might as
well be poisonous to me because I know
you don't like that I like them so but
thank you for that answer Pastor Loma
King what does the Beast that comes out
of the earth represent wow
uh this is a 30-second question or 30
minutes three minutes for this one
Revelation chapter 13 verses 11 and 12
gives us the foundation for that
question I'll go ahead and read it the
Bible says
then I saw another Beast coming up out
of the earth and he had two horns like a
lamb and spoke like a dragon I'll leave
out verse 12 for now to understand that
verse is important to fill in the blanks
that's the verse that's the text but
there's a context to it you find and and
I want to just kind of give a quick
little lesson here on the language of
Revelation
you know how how ironic it is that you
find in Revelation
chapter 12 it says Rejoice O heavens and
you who dwell in them but woe to the
inhabitants of the earth and of the Sea
of the earth and of the sea notice is it
coincidental or is it prophetic that the
two words mentioned are highlighted in
the very next chapter because the earth
and the Sea the inhabitants of the earth
and the Sea so the natural question is
do people inhabit the Sea and the answer
is no but do did people inhabit the
prophetic see the answer is yes because
the first piece of Revelation 13 is the
beast from the sea
and the second one is the beast from the
earth so the woeing there is talking
about these two places where populations
were very uh very dense and then we were
very sparse but then you find that the
dragon who was angry with the woman is
trying to find ways to destroy her and
it says Revelation 12 15 so the serpent
spewed water out of his mouth like a
flood after the woman
that he might cause her to be carried
away by the flood but the Earth verse 16
but the Earth helped the woman and the
Earth opened its mouth so we find The
woman there represents represents the
church the church is going through
persecution in Europe
and God opened America up the Earth
helped the woman and the woman was the
church that came and found refuge in
America that's why Nation this nation
has a Christian Base a base that is
based on people that were fleeing
persecution came to America where they
can practice Protestant values the Earth
helped the woman so the answer to the
Earth Beast is the representation of a
power that offers two things because it
had two horns like a lamb now lamb why
like a lamb meaning two things Jesus the
lamb secondly a subtle soft and
non-threatening Country offering the
Solitude the church needs what were the
two horns we had the Protestant form of
religion and a republic as a form of
government so in a nutshell that
represents the United States but there's
one caution because the dragon that hate
the woman gave power to the Beast that
came out of the sea eventually this
lamb-like nation will do what the other
two Powers have done and begin to speak
like a dragon but at the present time we
have the freedom of religion and we know
that that is slowly but surely being
eroded but that represents the prophetic
power of the United States
I don't know how you did that in three
minutes I
don't know Daniel is it okay to work
late Saturday afternoon this is from
caxi I hope I'm saying that right out of
Australia
all right I I believe I'm talking and
responding to somebody who recognizes
and accepts the authority of the Ten
Commandments particularly the fourth
Commandment here regarding the Sabbath
and the short answer from the Bible is
it depends upon when the Sun goes down
what are the hours of the Sabbath I'll
move you through five texts here Genesis
1 verse 5. so the evening and the
morning were the first day the day
begins with the evening or the the
nighttime dark hours and concludes with
the light hours Leviticus 23 32 from
evening to evening you shall celebrate
your stabbath your celebrate sorry from
your Sabbath Deuteronomy 16 Verse 6 then
you shall sacrifice the Passover at
Twilight the King James says at even
there at the going down of the Sun so
more specifically the sunset Nehemiah 13
verse 19 and it came to pass that when
the Gates of Jerusalem began to be dark
before the Sabbath I commanded that the
gate should be shut and remain shut
until after the Sabbath and so as it is
getting dark preparing for soon to be
sundown and finally conclusively here
Mark 132 at evening when the sun had set
they brought to him all who were sick
and those were demon-possessed to Jesus
for healing so the hours of the Sabbath
begin and end when the Sun goes down
whether that's 4 P.M or 9 pm
so what does the bible then say about
the hours of the Sabbath remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy six days you
shall labor and do all your work but the
seventh day is the Sabbath of the Lord
your God in it you shall not do any work
right during those hours and at the end
of the command then the Lord blessed the
Sabbath day and hallowed it how much of
it all of it and so it's clear that we
should not complete our weekly labor or
pleasure during the usual Church hours
but the hours of the Sabbath are not
more holy in the middle or more holy
during the light parts or during the
church hours than they are at the edges
every moment of the Sabbath from start
to finish is a gift and a blessing that
is desirable to us it's not a matter of
a few less significant hours that we had
to spill over into but it's a matter of
loyalty and obedience to God out of love
not because of a legalistic requirement
but because of what he's done for us we
long for and love to spend time with him
in this special way where his Grace and
goodness is poured out to us so let me
challenge you not not with something to
do but with something to think instead
of thinking about what we feel the
Sabbath might take away from us ask God
to help you understand what the Sabbath
adds to you what is it that is a
blessing so we can treasure those holy
moments rather than calculating which
parts of it are more important or
significant than others and then let me
encourage you to stand up for and live
by that conviction because you may not
know it now but there will be people who
will see your conviction your obedience
to that conviction and their lives will
be changed you'll find out in heaven
people saw God working in you and it
bore fruit for righteousness in their
lives too amen amen excellent answer yes
it's interesting that the Commandment
the fourth Commandment that begins with
remember is the one that's most often
forgotten or dismissed yes yes mother is
there any significance in Mary referring
to Jesus as rabbanai in John chapter 20
verse 16. yes so the term Robin
is used only twice in the Bible Mark 10
51 and John 20 verse 16. in ancient
times this was a Jewish title for of
respect for learned persons and
spiritual instructors
in Mark as Jesus was leaving Jericho
there was a blind man begging by the
side of the road his name was Bartimaeus
and Jesus was passing by him and he
shouted out son of David Son of David
have mercy on me and he kept shouting it
son of David have mercy on me and people
were trying to get him to shut up but he
wouldn't because he knew that Jesus was
passing by this was his shot right of
healing so Jesus Stood Still I love that
that word says Jesus Stood Still and
commanded that he brought to him and he
said what would you have me do for you
and Bartimaeus said rabona that I might
receive my sight and in my margin in the
Bible it said raboni means my great one
so then let's go to John and Jesus did
restore his sight which is amazing then
we go to John 20 and we look at Mary and
we see Mary Weeping at the Tomb of Jesus
and she doesn't know where he is but she
sees Jesus standing there and she
doesn't recognize him she thinks he's
the gardener
and she doesn't know who he is until he
calls her by name and he says Mary
and when he called her by name she
turned and she said to him for Bon I she
knew that voice it was the voice that
she had heard so many times before
casting out demons showing compassion
and healing to the sick
she knew his voice John 10 1-3 says most
assuredly I say to you he who does not
enter the Sheepfold by the door but
climbs up some other way the same as the
thief and a robber but he who enters by
the door is The Shepherd of the sheep to
him the doorkeeper opens and the sheep
hear his voice and he calls his own
Sheep by name and leads them out and
let's not minimize the significance of
Jesus calling Mary by her name Isaiah 43
1-3 says fear not for I have redeemed
you I've called you by your name your
mind when you pass through the waters
I'll be with you and through the through
the rivers they will not overflow you
when you walk through the fire you will
not be burned neither will the flame
Scorch you for I am the Lord your God
the Holy One of Israel your savior we
will know that the Lord knows Us by name
he calls us by name and we are his we
are Redeemed by him and so owner my
great one my teacher that's the voice
that we're to respond to that's the
voice that we hear in our hearts that we
know that we want to follow in every way
amen amen beautiful answer I thought
you're about to start preaching praise
God Lord I love it I love that Isaiah 43
I love that that's the offering after
that amen that was beautiful very
incredible if you're just joining us at
home and you're wondering how can I
submit my questions these questions have
been wonderful but I've got some burning
on my mind and in my heart let me tell
you how you can do that you can text us
at
618-228-3975 again that's
618-228-3975 or send us an email
bibleqa at
3abn.tv again that's bibleqa at
3abn.tv and if you're on Instagram you
can always send us a direct message at
3abn underscore official again that's
3abn underscore official Pastor Lowe
McCain we're going to come to you with
this question this is your four minute
question here can you clarify when Jesus
died if Jesus spent three days in the
grave the same amount of time Jonah
spent in the belly of the fish Good
Friday doesn't add up this is from
Christine out of Baltimore okay I would
agree when you try to use our timing one
of the challenges we face is using
trying to fit biblical stories into our
the way that we count time today which
is something that we are put at a
disadvantage you know the Bible when you
read the Bible the days are broken down
into what we call watches you had four
watches of the day you had four watches
of the night that's why we talked about
the morning watch as you read the
morning watch and that's why when the
disciples were speaking in tongues
somebody said they may be drunk but the
response was it's only the third hour of
the day while the day began they broke
it down from 6 a.m to 9 that's the first
watch nine to noon second watch noon to
three Third Watch and three to six the
Fourth Watch of the day and the same
thing for the evening when the Fourth
Watch of the day was done you have
evening First Watch from six to nine
second watch nine to noon nine to
midnight that's why it's called midnight
because the night already started we try
to fit this 24-hour day period which the
day still has the 20 23 hours and 56
minutes but the way they counted time is
where we find ourselves at a
disadvantage the other thing is the way
that we count days today if I said if I
said to you Jason I'll see you in three
days well you'll you'll start counting
tomorrow the next day the next day but
that's not the case in the Bible Luke 13
verse 32 and he said to them Jesus
responding to the disciples go tell that
fox behold I cast out demons and perform
cures today and tomorrow and the third
day so he's including the day why is he
including today because we don't have
inclusive Reckoning which in the
scriptures any part of the day included
the whole day the next one next thing we
have to keep in mind is when you go to
Matthew 16 21 Matthew 17 23 Matthew 2019
Matthew 27 64. Mark 9 31 Luke 24 7 you
find one consistent theme is
Jesus said I would rise the third day
even when the Roman government was
appointing centurions to guard the tomb
this said in Matthew 27 64 therefore
command that the tomb be made secure
until the third day lest the disciples
come by night and steal them away and
say to the people he has risen from the
dead so the last deception will be worse
than the first they secured it till the
third day not after the third day and so
the key here is the inclusive Reckoning
aspect of it so when does the Day begin
now tonight when you when the sun sets
if it's a Monday night
then you have entered into
Tuesday night then Tuesday when the sun
sets you you enter Wednesday night then
Wednesday the evening and the morning
when you count it accordingly evening
morning evening morning evening morning
you easily come up with the three days
and the three nights but now this is the
most important aspect the Bible never
said he had to be in this tomb 72 hours
and this is where people are really
losing it because if he had to be in the
Tomb 72 hours what day would he rise
the fourth day
um this is where people are having a
difficult time well he was not in the
Tomb 72 hours which is what we had the
24 times three no the Bible never said
he had to be in the Tomb 72 hours it
says Luke 24 7 the son of man must be
delivered into the hands of sinful men
and be crucified and the third day rise
again any part of that day means that
day he didn't say the morning part or
the evening part but that he rose the
third day and you know what the good
news is he rose the third day amen so
let's get away from the inclusive aspect
like the guy in um the Holy Land said we
have six places that we think Jesus was
buried but he said the good news is he's
not in any one of those places amen
Jesus has risen and he rose the third
day amen amen yeah that seems to be a
question that a lot of people have I've
heard that quite a bit uh Daniel can you
please explain Romans chapter 14
especially verses 5 6 and 14. this is
your Foreman question and it comes from
Jamie okay Jamie at first glance it may
seem that Paul is saying pick any day to
be your holy day and God doesn't care
what you eat doesn't really matter but
let's get into it here Romans 14 in the
first half of 15 are Paul is dealing
with the issue of how you treat people
you disagree with there's two issues
that were on display there in Rome
they're the issue of days and the issue
of food starting us off in verse 1 Paul
says receive one who is weak in the
faith but not to disputes over doubtful
things doubtful things would be areas
where God's word had not given clear
instructions so keep that in mind this
is not regarding days or Foods where
God's word has not spoken clearly so
first the issue of days and I'm reading
from the new King James version which is
important here in verse 5 and 6. one
person esteems one day above another
another esteems every day alike Let each
be fully convinced in his own mind in
other words don't be led by preference
or convenience or teachers but know a
reason for what you believe from the
word of God not just because you like it
he who observes the day this is verse 6
observes it to the Lord and He who does
not observe the day to the Lord he does
not observe it he who eats eats to the
Lord for he gives thanks for he gives
God thanks and he who does not eat to
the Lord he does not eat and gives God
thanks now some English translations are
going to add a word here one person
esteems One Day More sacred or more holy
and those words are not in the Greek
text there this is not dealing with a
sacred day nowhere in this chapter does
it mention the law or the Ten
Commandments or worship or obedience
things associated with the Sabbath those
issues were all dealt with in Romans 1
to 8. the text is not talking about the
Sabbath here because we know that there
were not people in any place who
esteemed every day to be the Sabbath
like it mentioned in the text verse 6
adds the appropriate interpretation he
who eats and he who does not eat so
apparently there were those in Rome who
were advocating days of fasting this is
a day that we should fast and these are
days that you should eat and if you're
not participating in that then you must
not really be loyal to God and
commentators of many denominations agree
that this is not a reference to the
Bible's Sabbath from The Ten
Commandments now the issue of vegetables
verse 2 for One Believes he may eat all
things but he who is weak eats only
vegetables still revolving around the
context of food and a letter that Paul
wrote about a year earlier First
Corinthians chapter 8 appears to be
addressing the same issue if you went to
sell your meat at the marketplace at the
Agora you would likely offer that food
as a gift to the gods and so then a
Christian in good conscience who'd come
from a pagan background would say I
can't eat that food it's been offered to
the gods well that really left you only
one option to eat vegetables and there
were other Christians who said who are
not saved by what goes into our body
we're saved through faith in Jesus
Christ those gods are nothing there's
nothing to them and so the issue here
that they're arguing about is eating
just vegetables or meat offered to Idols
this is not about the principles of
Health that's not what was at stake and
so when Paul says in verse 14 to him who
considers anything to be unclean to him
it is unclean he is instructing you not
to violate your convictions that you
hold before God if you believe it is
God's word from for for you from God's
word and from the Holy Spirit then do
what God asks you to do all right so the
two issues here what you eat and when
you eat it and number one know what you
believe and why from God's word don't
violate your convictions and treat
people with loving respect welcoming
them even if you have differences
amen amen well put well said mom why did
Jesus cry on the cross father why have
you forsaken me
this comes from one of our Instagram
followers yes
Our Savior bore the sins of the world
on himself now imagine the worst sin
that you can possibly think of whether
it's murder or rape or pedophilia any of
these things all of these things Jesus
Paid the price for it on the sinless one
was laid the sins of everyone past
present and future Isaiah 53 verses 5
and 6 says but he was wounded for our
transgressions he was bruised for our
iniquities the chastisement of our peace
was upon him and by his stripes we are
healed all we like sheep have turned
astray I've gone astray we've turned
everyone to his own way and the lord has
laid on him the iniquities of us all
sin separates us from God Isaiah 59
verses 1 and 2 says behold the Lord's
hand does not shortened that it cannot
save nor his ear heavy that it cannot
hear but your iniquities have separated
you from your God and your sins have
hidden his face from you so that he will
not hear it was this separation that
tore Christ's heart apart because he was
carrying the sins of the world on him he
was bearing our iniquities and that
separated him from God think about it he
never felt separated from the father
before ever and this time he couldn't
even sense his presence he was so close
to the father that he said in John 14 9
he who has seen me has seen the father
so on the cross Jesus had to accomplish
his mission of Salvation without sensing
the presence of his father he had to
believe and trust that he would be
Resurrected it he had to know that his
sacrifice was acceptable to the father
all while knowing at that moment that
his father was separated from him he was
in agony
he was in pain because he could not
sense
the presence of the father and so that's
why he ended up saying my God my God why
have you forsaken me he felt alone and
you know when you think about how Jesus
was crucified the the pictures have him
in a loincloth but actually he was naked
so he was taunted he was beaten he was
spat upon he was
degraded
and yet he could not sense if he could
have felt the presence of his father I
think he it it would have made it
somewhat easier for him but everything
was dark for him and so
the Lord carried our sins he felt
forsaken
but thank the Lord he's not in the Tomb
as Pastor said he's not in his tomb he
has been resurrected amen amen praise
God for that that sacrifice when people
say that God is Harsh and exacting it's
like how could you think that when Jesus
did all of that yeah for us yeah Pastor
Loma Kang Matthew chapter 10 verse 28
says we must not fear those who can kill
the soul but we should fear Him who can
kill both soul and body this seems to
imply two entities in our bodies the
soul and the body how do we reconcile
the biblical teachings that the body is
a soul one entity and is not separate
from the soul please explain this from
Lucy sure thank you so much Lucy
actually the question was rhetorical
actually because she answered the
question but let me go ahead and read
the passage you you quoted the scripture
but just for the benefit of repetition
we'll read it again
Matthew 10 verse 28 and do not fear
Those Who Kill the body but cannot kill
the soul but rather fear Him who was
able
to destroy both soul and body and hell
now right away we don't see the soul as
anything Immortal because the soul can
be destroyed so when you describe them
as separate let's go back to the very
creation story in Genesis 2 and verse 7
you know the Bible says that God
breathed into atoms and nostrils the
Breath of Life
and Adam became a living Soul there's
quite a difference but all you have to
do is change the word you could say have
a living Soul or became a living soul
that one word makes all the difference
in our perception we don't have a living
Soul hanging around in our bodies
waiting to get out and that's the
inference that many people that believe
in something called neoplatonism it's a
very good study it's a very in-depth
study that shows where this belief came
from it taught that the body the soul
and the spirit was separate that man
when he started breathing and this is
taught and I'm just very candid in
Mormonism they talk about a cycle these
souls in heaven that are inserted into
the body at the birth of a child that's
why in this particular practice many
babies are born to house the soul that
pre-existed that's not scriptural God
brought Adam to life when he breathed so
there was no pre-existence we didn't
have the soul wondering now I wonder
whose body I'm going to get or where am
I going to go after this person dies so
Abraham doesn't have a soul walking
around where he died Adam didn't have a
soul walking around where he died the
Bible makes it very very clear and even
on the ark
this very inference goes right back to
the time of creation God breathed into
Adam's nostrils the breath of life and
he became a living Soul job 27 verse 3
says all the while my breath is in me
and the spirit of God is in my nostrils
so the word there went the word their
spirit and breath are the very same word
in the Hebrew ruak meaning Breath of
Life Giving life to something that has
no life and I reiterate giving life to
something that has no life if we were
inherently Immortal the Bible wouldn't
say in first Timothy 1 16 God Alone who
hath immortality now we're going to have
immortality but we don't have it it's a
promise right now but first Corinthians
15 verse 51 to 55 the Mortal that's us
will put on immortality those who are
corruptable will put on in corruption so
we don't have anything that's mortal
right now let me encourage you the
interchangeable word that's why the new
King James I thank the Lord for the
change they said man became a living
being it's that ethereal word soul that
made gave many false teachers room to
create this ethereal idea that you have
something rather than you are something
we are a living soul and we can die
because the Bible says in Ezekiel 18 for
the soul that sinneth it shall die amen
and he said neoplatonism neoplatonism
that's a good study of power all right
Daniel Perrin can you please explain
Luke chapter 16 verses 6 through 8. this
sounds like Jesus was condoning
dishonesty I'm sure this isn't the case
but I would like to understand what it
means
all right many people consider this to
be a hard Parable to understand so I'm
going to go back to verse one and I'm
just going to read through the whole
Parable especially if you're not
familiar with it Jesus said to his
disciples there was a certain rich man
who had a steward and an accusation was
brought against him that this man was
wasting his Goods so he called him and
said to him what is this I hear about
you give an account of your stewardship
for you can no longer be steward
and the stewards said within himself
what shall I do for my master is taking
the stewardship away from me I cannot
dig I'm too ashamed to beg I have res I
have resolved what to do that when I am
put out of the stewardship they may
receive me into their houses
so he called every one of the his
master's debtors to him and said to the
first how much do you owe my master and
he said a hundred measures of oil he
said to him take your bill and sit down
quickly and write 50. then he said to
another and how much do you owe so he
said a hundred measures of Wheat and he
said to him take your bill and write 80.
so the master condemn commended the
unjust Steward because he had dealt
shrewdly for the sons of this world are
more shrewd in their generation than are
the sons of Light
now some of the principles here we are
stewards back to this issue again
managing God's resources and like the
steward in this story here we have not
been faithful we've been careless we've
wasted and to some degree uh
disappointed the master in wasting his
Goods that he has entrusted to us and
like the steward our time of stewardship
is coming to a close whatever it is that
we've been entrusted with whatever
whatever skills and abilities and
relationships and finances those things
are in our hands for a time and then we
won't have control over them any longer
we're going to have to give an account
though for everything that we've done
with them so what does this Steward do
well he quickly he recognizes time is
short he does everything in his power to
strengthen his friendship with his
master's creditors so that he will have
some type of some type of of help
afterwards he's looking on ahead to the
Future he's sending his resource is
ahead of him so he has something beyond
what he has right now his eye is to the
Future planning for what is to come and
so Jesus here says that the master does
not commend him for his dishonesty but
for his wisdom planning ahead and Jesus
desires the same thing of you to be
looking ahead not just to this life
which is limited which is going to come
to an end what can you do quickly right
now that is going to have a lasting
benefit that will send your resources on
ahead Jesus says lay up your Treasures
in Heaven where moth and rust do not
destroy and the thieves do not break in
and steal the children of the world do
this they recognize and it says that
they are wise in their generation
they're storing up for the future and
should we be outdone by them don't store
up here on Earth send your resources
ahead say Lord I want to have something
in the future waiting for me let's be
wise and lay up Treasures in Heaven amen
and well said mom how do we submit and
let God take control of our life this is
from Elena off Instagram
this is a really good question Elena
because we need to know how can we let
God
take control of our lives and I I think
there are five steps here in in this
process of submission the first one is
to invite Jesus into your life see
unlike Satan Jesus wants us to let him
in Revelation 3 20 says behold I stand
at the door and knock if anyone hears my
voice and opens the door I will come
into him and dine with him and he with
me end quote notice that Jesus didn't
say he's going to let himself in no you
have to open the door to him and so
that's the first thing the decision to
open the door is up to you
he will come in and eat with you and you
with him that means you'll have a
relationship with him so that's the
first thing and this also gives him
Authority or permission to enter when
Adam and Eve sinned Satan became the
ruler of this world and in John 12 31
Jesus says now is the Judgment of this
world now the ruler of this world will
be cast out and in John 14 30
it says the ruler of this world is
coming and he has nothing in me so we
have to invite Jesus in and the second
step is found in James 4 7. James tells
us submit yourselves then to God resist
the devil and he will flee from you what
does it mean to submit it means to yield
to him we must make a decision to obey
Jesus to obey him consistently always in
all ways submission is putting God's
will ahead of our own it's not automatic
we have to consciously make a decision
to submit our will to God and when we do
that we resist the devil and he'll go
away temporarily at least and then the
more we resist him the stronger we get
the more the less power Satan has over
us and the more we become like Christ
and then the third step is to recognize
your enemy and your savior Ephesians 6
12 says for we do not wrestle against
flesh and blood but against
principalities against Powers against
the rulers of the darkness of this age
against spiritual hosts of wickedness in
the Heavenly places now how can we fight
that we can't but Jesus can we recognize
his power his authority over the enemy
and Jesus fights the battle but we have
to be armed what does Armor do it
protects us from the battle so we have
to put on the whole armor of God
Ephesians 6
and Ephesians 6 12-18 but I won't read
it all it says therefore take up the
whole armor of God that you may be able
to withstand in the evil day and having
done all to stand and then the fourth
step in this submission process is to
develop our relationship with God
stay in prayer throughout the day first
Thessalonians 5 17 says to pray without
ceasing talk to Jesus as you would a
respected friend he is your friend he is
your advocate he is your mediator he is
there through every situation
read the word to learn more about his
ways and will and then lastly share your
testimony we can let others know what
Jesus has done in our own lives
Revelation 12 11 says and they overcame
him the Devil by the blood of the lamb
and by the word of their testimony and
they did not love their lives to the
death so we can do these five things
invite Jesus into your life submit
through obedience to God's will
recognize your enemy and your savior
develop your relationship with God and
share your testimony and if you do that
you are submitting to God you are
inviting him into your life you are
resisting the devil and you are on that
road to sanctification because the holy
spirit will work through you to impact
others so it is a process it's not just
something that's automatic but it's a
decision to submit amen amen that at all
sounds like a faith building exercise as
well in addition to that I want to throw
out a little bonus question and this is
for anybody
how do you recommend
studying the word of God how do you
recommend approaching the study of God's
word
for though it depends on what level you
are if you're just a beginner if you
want to be more advanced the Bible is a
book that reaches all levels it starts
out with simple books I always recommend
if a person never read the Bible the
Bible before establish the god Factor
first read the book of Genesis and then
establish the Christ Factor read the
book of John and then then start
expanding Matthew Mark and Luke expand
that and then because if you try to read
the Bible chronologically for a beginner
it could become
it's like just putting on a snorkel and
diving into the middle of the ocean you
run out of oxygen very very quickly so
start with the basic things establish
the factor that God is the creator of
all established a beginning story of the
foundation of humanity and then go ahead
and understand who Jesus is by reading
the gospels and then you can get at the
rise of Paul beautiful about salvation
righteousness and then when you get
stronger you could dive into the books
like Psalm and then begin to open from
up open up from there Daniel we know
that this is God's book and his message
and inspired through the Holy Spirit and
understood through the holy spirit so my
advice is definitely ask God to lead you
I mean before you open up the Bible take
it take a moment or a few moments or
minutes of prayer and say I want to
connect with the author uh so that the
inspired words not only I'll understand
them but live by them and I guess the
other thing that I say is that you know
we want to study God's word but there
are so many pressing responsibilities
and urgencies in our life and really
carve out time and protect that say this
I'm going to do this I had a friend who
said I will not eat physical food in the
day until I've eaten spiritual food and
he was an owner of a successful business
and there were days when the pressing
concerns of business were on him as soon
as he woke up and he said there's times
when I have not been able to eat until
the evening time because things were
just on me and he said I'm not going to
put physical food in my body until I do
spiritual food that was his conviction
powerful powerful I love what I love
what you all said there and Mom right
after we take our short break we're
going to come back to you and I want to
hear your recommendations your
suggestions for studying the word I
can't believe our time is dwindling down
and these have been some excellent
questions with excellent answers and as
always I appreciate how you study the
word of God I want you to know how you
can submit your questions if you've
missed the times that we've told you
about it we're going to take a brief
break and we'll be right back
if you're enjoying our 3abian Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3abian Bible q a for answers from
God's word
wow well welcome back glad you stuck
with us we have about two minutes left
don't go anywhere though because we're
gonna get some good stuff in this last
two minutes mom how do you recommend
studying the Bible I think you you need
to I I want to kind of pick up on what
you said Daniel and what Pastor said you
need to have a special time make time
but have a special time that's just you
and God so that the Holy Spirit can can
talk to you it's nice to have a special
place as well you know a place where you
go and then of course you pray and you
ask God to give you whatever insights
you need for that day and the Lord will
will bless you as you make time and and
spend time in the word he will bless you
amen so I'm hearing the intentionality
the importance of intentionality that's
great I want to open up the floor now
for any final thoughts okay I'll give
you a shot first yeah I mentioned that
there are Bible translations that add
some words there and they're popular
translations and the thing thinking of
Romans 14 and that's just one area that
just reminds us that it's important to
pay attention to attention to what Bible
am I reading we'll go out and do
research on cars and we'll test drive
cars but this thing that's so much more
important pay attention to what you're
reading I like that don't don't just
pick up a book be aware of the impact
it's going to have on your life and the
other thing about it we talked about the
time of the resurrection of Jesus the
topic that comes up quite frequently let
me encourage you the most important
aspect is not the knowledge of his
resurrection but the knowledge of the
one that Rose you can be accurate on how
what time of day it was the location of
his burial when he was raised
but if you don't know him you could be
lost oh yes get to know the man and the
day will make a difference amen amen
well thank you all so much for coming on
and and sharing and answering these
questions thank you for joining us until
next time God bless you
[Music]
foreign